[Musique]
un 100 % consacré à la situation à
l'avenir de la télé c'est un sujet qui
intéresse de près les sénateurs puisque
depuis 2015 des travaux et des rapports
sont publiés à intervales réguliers
notamment en ce qui concerne
l'audiovisuel publique aujourd'hui la
commission de la culture auditionne le
président de l'arcom l'Autorité de
régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle on file en audition et on
en reparle juste
après monsieur le Président cette
audition est bien entendu l'occasion de
revenir comme on le fait chaque année
enfin com commment on le fait chaque
année sur votre rapport d'activité mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de faire un bilan
des deux premières années d'existence de
de l'arcom cette audition est aussi et
surtout l'occasion d'aborder avec vous
les nombreux sujets d'actualité lié à
l'audiovisuel et et au numérique
et cette année encore ils sont nombreux
il concerne bien entendu l'audiovisuel
public auquel les membres de la
commission demeurent particulièrement
attachés mais dont l'avenir suscite chez
bon nombre d'entre nous des
interrogations pour ne pas dire des des
inquiétudes ces interrogations
concernent d'abord la la stratégie du
gouvernement à l'égard des sociétés qui
le composent nous avons bien compris que
la réforme du de l'audiovisuel n'était
pas la priorité de de la ministre de la
Culture pour autant en décalant de de
moi en moi la présentation des nouveau
com nous en venons à nous interroger sur
la nature des des objectifs que
l'actionnaire public entend assigner aux
entreprises deaudiovisuel public pour la
période 2024-2028 c'est-à-dire qui
commence maintenant dans 3 semaines ces
inquiétudes portent également sur les
modalités de de financement des sociétés
de l'audiovisuel publ alors que la
poursuite du du financement via une
fraction de TVA est suspendu à une
éventuelle réforme de la loi organique
relative aux finances publiques nous
sommes là encore dans dans l'attente des
précisions du gouvernement sur ses
intentions concernant non pas 2024 comme
pour les com mais l'après 2025 et la
question du du financement je ne vous
demanderai pas monsieur le Président si
vous partagez l'ensemble de de ces
interrogations qui ont malheureusement
conduit le Sénat à rejeter les crédits
de l'audiovisuel public il y a une
dizaine de jours si j'ai bien conscience
qu'elle nous appartient pas de commenter
les choix du gouvernement ou plutôt son
absence de choix je ne peux résister à
l'envie de connaître le sentiment du
régulateur sur le climat d'incertitude
qu'ils font peser dans ces temps
troublés sur l'audiovisuel public ces
incertitudes sont d'autant plus
regrettable que les acteurs de
l'audiovisuel sont contraints de
poursuivre leur mutation pour répondre à
l'évolution des usages et des
technologie parmi ces mutations il en
est une dont nous avons débattu ici même
en en janvier dernier et qui concernait
la diffusion des services de radio sur
le numérique terrestre à l'occasion de
de cette table ronde vous aviez annoncer
votre intention en présence de
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
premièrement de donner un coup
d'accélérateur au au déploiement du DAB
plus afin de trouver une solution à la
saturation de la bande FM et également
de de préparer un livre blanc sur
l'avenir de la radio à l'image de
l'initiative prise en son temps par le
le régulateur britannique 1 an après ces
annonces pouvez-vous monsieur le
Président nous informer des des progrès
accomplis en ces deux domaines
l'ensemble des des idéteurs vous ont-ils
suivi sur un terrain qu'il semblait
appréhender faute d'accompagnement
financier suffisant de l'État monsieur
le Président
je je voudrais compléter ce propos
introductif par quelques mots sur la
lutte contre le le piratage à laquelle
notre commission bien entendu l'arcom
également est particulièrement attachée
nous avions organisé en octobre
2022 en présence de Denis Rapon une
table ronde sur la mise en œuvre de
l'article 3 de la loi du 25 octobre 2021
donnant à à l'arcom la possibilité de de
bloquer les les sites miroirs
retransmettant ilégalement les les
événements
sportif la question problématique du
partage des coûts du blocage avait été
évoqué de même que la nécessité
d'impliquer l'ensemble des
intermédiaires de l'écosystème internet
pour rendre la procédure encore plus
efficace où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui
et comment réagir à la à la
commercialisation florissante des
boîtiers d'IPT TV illégaux enfin
monsieur le Président nous sommes
intéressés de vous entendre sur la façon
dont les médias français couvrent le
conflit au Moyen-Orient vous avez
organisé il y a quelques jours une
réunion avec les les principaux acteurs
pourriez-vous nous nous préciser si vous
considérez que cette couverture par les
médias français de l'événement
correspond aux attentes ou aux exigences
de l'arcom je vais à présent monsieur le
Président vous laisser la parole non
sans avoir préalablement rappelé que
cette audition est diffusé en direct sur
le site internet du
sa monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs permettez-moi d'abord
d'exprimer mes mes vives félicitations à
toutes celles et tous ceux d'entre vous
qui ont été élus ou réélu à l'occasion
du du récent renouvellement du du Sénat
j'ai naturellement une pensée
particulière pour vous monsieur le
Président qui venait d'être reconduit à
la à la tête de cette belle commission
je je salue la désignation de Monsieur
Vial également comme rapporteur sur des
sujets que nous aurons en
partage et je suis très heureux que nous
puissions poursuivre nos échanges
auquels j'accorde vous le savez la plus
grande importance l'arcom a eu la chance
depuis 5 ans de toujours bénéficier à la
fois de l'écoute de votre commission
mais surtout de son de son soutien votre
commission dont l'investissement et
l'expertise reconnu de longue date dans
le domaine audiovisuel sont sont très
précieux pour l'ensemble du du secteur
les
défis auquels sont confrontés les
acteurs tant publics que privés de notre
p age audiovisuel rendent en effet plus
plus nécessaire que jamais l'attention
des pouvoirs publics dans leur ensemble
aux difficultés qu'il
rencontre la présentation devant votre
commission de notre premier rapport
d'activité en réalité puisque l'arcom a
vu le jour le 1er janvier
2022 va me permettre d'abord de revenir
sur le bilan de de l'autorité une
autorité très profondément
transformée sous impulsion du Parlement
et tout particulièrement sous
l'impulsion du du Sénat tout
particulièrement transformé depuis
depuis 5 ans et qui est pleinement
opérationnelle depuis sa sa
création d'évoquer ensuite les les
transformations qui sont à l'œuvre dans
le secteur et leurs implications pour
les opérateurs comme pour les pouvoirs
publics et puis enfin d'aborder devant
vous les grands chantiers de l'arcom
pour l'année à venir qui sera vous le
savez la dernière année de mon de mon
mandat comme on témoigne ce premier
rapport d'activité l'arcom a été à pied
d'œuvre dès sa création pour remplir ses
différentes missions et achever sa
création quelques chiffres parlent de
même en
2022 le collège s'est réuni 77 fois en
collège plier a
étudié 10000 dossiers organisé plus de
38 auditions euh sur les questions du du
secteur je vais rappeler quelques
échéances de cette première année
d'exercice l'organisation des élections
présidentielles et législatives qui
naturellement ont très fortement
mobilisé nos équipes en charge du du
contrôle du pluralisme en lien étroit
avec les médias audiovisuels mais aussi
au titre de nos compétences avec les
plateformes numériques les partis
politiques bien évidemment et les
équipes des différents candidats nous
préparons d'ors et déjà très activement
un scrutin qui aura nous le savons tous
des enjeux majeurs qui est le scrutin
européen de juin de juin
2024 l'année 2022 a été marqué aussi
vous le savez par d'importants projets
de consolidation dans le secteur
audiovisuel qui ont beaucoup mobilisé
les les services de l'autorité je pense
au projet de rapprochement entre TF1 et
M6 qui qui n'a pu aboutir mais je pense
aussi au projet de PAA maintenant
autorisé
du groupe ivindi sur le groupe la
gardire je pense également au processus
de nomination que nous avons dû mené
l'année dernière d'une part à la
présidence de Radio France et d'autre
part à la présidence de France
médiamonde je pense également au
renforcement de notre engagement
européen international d'abord au sein
du réseau européen des régulateurs
l'erga où l'arcom joue un rôle central
mais aussi au sein du réseau francophone
qui rassemble t tous les régulateurs qui
ont notre langue en partage le réram et
dont nous avons pris la présidence en
2022 jusqu'à la fin de
2024 je pense enfin vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le Président dans votre propos
liminminire à la lutte contre le
piratage avec les les nouveaux outils
dont le Parlement a doté l'arcom et et
le Sénat a joué un rôle décisif en la
matière pour la seule année 2022 c'est
plus de 100 600 sites illicites que nous
avons bloqué pour cette première année
dans le seul domaine du sport c'est
considérable il y a incontestablement un
avant en après à la date d'aujourd'hui
on est au-delà de 2500 sites donc c'est
un effort tout à fait spectaculaire et à
cet égard on pourrait y revenir nous
nous nous pensons à l'expérience que le
cadre juridique adopté en en 2021
pourrait probablement être encore
renforcé concernant le piratage culturel
cette fois je pense la lutte contre le
piratage dans le domaine du du cinéma en
accélérant par quelques ajustements du
du cadre juridique en accélérant les
délais de traitement pour limiter les
phénomènes de de contournement et
étendre la portée du dispositif au-delà
de ces importants dossiers donc qui ont
marqué notre première année d'activité
nous avons connu d'autres dossiers très
structurants pour une première année
d'exercice nous avons lancé un
observatoire des des podcasts qui est un
un de ces mouvement nouveaux que nous
observons dans dans le secteur
audiovisuel et qui va jouer bien sûr un
un rôle très important l'accélération du
déploiement de la radio numérique
terrestre qui va couvrir des désormais
dans quelques semaines plus de 60 % de
la population métropolitaine donc on a
franchi maintenant des étapes
décisives je pense également à notre
campagne enfants et écran au titre de
nos activités de protection des des plus
jeunes ou à la conclusion des des
contrats climat qui marquent
l'investissement de notre autorité sur
les sujets de protection de
l'environnement en parallèle il nous a
fallu mener à bien la transformation de
notre institution pour déployer la
création de de l'arcom nombreux
chantiers ont été menés de front notre
collège a été élargi à neu membres neu
membres désignés par C autorités
différentes nous avons adopté un plan
stratégique pour l'autorité qui couvre
la période qui nous mènera jusqu'à
2025 nous avons créé au titre de nos
nouvelles compétences une direction de
la création qui couvre l'ensemble de la
protection du champ de la création de la
fixation des obligations en matière de
financement de la production qui pèse
sur nos acteurs jusqu'à la protection du
droit
d'auteur nous avons organisé la montée
en puissance de notre nouvelle direction
des plateformes en ligne pour mettre en
œuvre les nouvelles compétences qui sont
les nôtres en matière de de régulation
des grands acteurs de l'Internet nous
avons conformément à la loi organisé la
fusion de nos instances sociales de nos
règlements de gestion et nous avons
regroupé nos locaux pour accueillir
l'ensemble de nos collaborateurs à la
suite de la fusion donc entre l'ancien
CSA et l'ancienne
adopie nous allons d'ailleurs je vous en
informe devoir chercher une nouvelle
implantation puisque notre propriétaire
nous a fait part de son intention
d'effectuer des travaux de
restructuration majeur dans notre site
historique la tour mIRABO et donc nous
allons devoir la la quitter nous
eménagerons dans de nouveaux locaux au
plus tard fin
2024 donc décidément ce ce mandat aura
été particulièrement
riche puisqu'il s'achèvera y compris par
une implantation nouvelle de de
l'autorité un un mot maintenant si vous
le voulez bien sur les transformations
de notre pays
audiovisuel qui implique à nos yeux et
et je sais que votre commission l'est et
je l'en remercie qui implique à nos yeux
d'être particulièrement à l'écoute et en
appui de l'ensemble de nos opérateurs
nationaux publics ou
privé pour les accompagner dans leur
indispensable réorientation
stratégique ces transformations on
pourra y revenir sont à mes yeux de de
trois ordres nous observons d'abord vous
vous savez tous une
profonde transformation je parlerai même
volontiers d'une révolution des usages
consomme plus les contenus audiovisuels
comme on le consommait dans ma dans ma
jeunesse sur le canapé familial en
regardant l'écran de télévision au
salon cette transformation des usages
s'exprime notamment par la bascule de la
consommation des contenus vers des
consommation de plus en plus à la
demande la durée d'écoute individuelle
qui est l'instrument de de mesure pour
tous les opérateurs du secteur la durée
d'écoute individuelle de la télévision
est en diminution structurelle
elle a diminué de près de 20 % sur les
TR dernières années
impressionnant plus de 50 % des foyers
Français sont aujourd'hui abonnés à au
moins un service de vidéo à la demande
et ils en consomment chaque jour un peu
plus l'âge du téléspectateur l'âge moyen
du téléspectateur de la
télévision traditionnelle est
aujourd'hui pratiquement de 58
ans il est proche de 65 ans pour le
service public et les jeunes les jeunes
générations dont nous faisons tous
partie privilégie naturellement d'autres
vecteurs d'autres
contenus
deux exemples 2 tiers des moins de 15
ans 2/ers des moins de 15 ans se rendent
chaque jour sur snapchat et les réseaux
les réseaux sociaux constituent le le
premier mode d'accès à
l'information pour 71 % des 15 34
ans c'est une véritable révolution des
usages avec une fracturation des contenu
de la consommation des contenus qui est
très très
frappante cette transformation des
habitudes elle est portée aussi par de
nouveaux équipements
audiovisuels les écrans se
multiplient en moyenne aujourd'hui dans
les foyers français si on inclut ces
petits outils qui qui permettent de
consommer des contenus audiovisuels les
écrans en moyenne sont aujourd'hui de 6
par foyer
88 % des foyers français sont maintenant
équipés d'un téléviseur
connecté le téléviseur devient chaque
jour un peu plus vous allez acheter un
téléviseur demain chez un un
distributeur dont je ne citerai pas le
nom des marques les téléviseurs sont de
plus en plus des magasins d'application
à l'instar de de nos téléphones et
d'ailleurs c'est là aussi très frappant
l'usage hors
télévision représente déjà un tiers de
la moitié du temps qui consacre les les
plus jeunes de 4 à 34
ans la réalité des usages et et des
modes de réception entraînent une
reconfiguration du
marché les plateformes de de streaming
vidéo les Netflix Disney plus Amazon
Prime Apple toutes celles qui qui vont
arriver HBO HBO max paramon plus j'en
passe c'est des meilleurs les
plateformes de de streaming vidéo
constitue pour nos groupes nationaux une
concurrence
croissante qui pèse bien sûr sur
l'acquisition sur les coûts sur la
diffusion de programmes inéit sur
l'accès au
talent notre paysage est également
percuté par le poids croissant des
acteurs du du numérique fameux gfam qui
sont pour la plupart vous le savez
extrauropéens et qui absorbent à eux
seul plus de la moitié des ressources
publicitaires consacrées au médias 2
tiers des recettes de la publicité
numérique en France ont été captés en
2022 par trois opérateurs Google meta
Amazon et bien évidemment tout ça n'est
pas neutre pour nos TF1 nos M6 et tous
nos opérateurs
nationaux dans ce contexte il Orte de
préserver le modèle économique et
culturel de nos acteurs nationaux tous
nos groupes audiovisuels
sont engagé deén avant dans des
réorientations
stratégiques celles-ci les amène à
consentir des investissements
importants technologiques ou dans les
contenus et c'est d'ailleurs c
réorientation stratégique un signe qu'il
faut saluer ici on ne le fait peut-être
pas suffisamment du dynamisme et de la
résilience de nos entreprises je pense
qu'on peut être fier de nos groupes
audiovisuels du dynamisme de leur dirige
nos groupes qu'il soi public ou privés
sont aujourd'hui engagés dans un
mouvement pour aller chercher les
publics là où ils sont et notamment les
publics les plus jeunes que j'ai évoqué
toujours que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
en renforçant leur stratégie digitale en
ajustant leur stratégie
éditoriale et en diversifiant leur
modalité de
distribution pour les acteurs pr cette
orientation ce mouvement cette
tréorientation stratégique implique bien
sûr de dégager des marges de manœuvre
financière en particulier pour faire
face à la concurrence sur les revenus
publicitaires vous savez que les revenus
pour le secteur de la radio en matière
de publicité sont à la baisse pour la
télévision dira qu'ils sont à peu près
étales à peu près à peu près stables à
un moment où les acteurs doivent
consentir comme je viens d'expliquer des
investissements et c'est vrai que de ce
point de vue face au aux asymétries
réglementaires qui existent aujourd'hui
des acteurs du numérique qui peuvent
capter tranquillement cette ressource
nos acteurs qui sont soumis à des
contraintes réglementaires importantes
l'heure est en tout cas probablement
venue d'engager une réflexion sur des
adaptations je pense à la question
récurrente des secteurs interdits de de
publicité je pense à la question qu'on a
souvent évoqué dans cet enceinte des des
mentions légales pour la radio qui qui
contraignne bien évidemment leur
financement pour l'audiovisuel public
monsieur le Président que vous avez
évoqué on sait le rôle fondamental qu'il
joue dans l'équilibre du paysage
audiovisuel 30 % des des audiences bien
évidemment un rôle majeur dans dans le
financement de la création un rôle
majeur dans l'information de nos
compatriotes pour le diovisel public
dont l'indépendance et les modalités
d'action doivent être
garanties le gouvernement a fait
connaître la trajectoire purannuelle de
de financement qu'il propose pour la
période
2428 l'arcom a souvent eu l'occasion de
le dire pourra évoquer cela au cours de
l'audition un service public fort c'est
c'est bien sûr un service
public bien financé avec les les
garanties de financement qui s'y attache
mais c'est aussi un service public qui
sait organiser les synergies
éditoriale et
organisationnelle qui sont nécessaires
pour remplir au mieux sa mission au
service des Français l'arcom l'a
régulièrement dit rejoignant des
préoccupations que votre commission a
souvent exprimé la réussite du du
rapprochement des réseaux régionaux de
France télévision et de radio
France tout comme le développement de de
France Info exigeront probablement en
tout cas c'est notre sentiment une
réponse appropriée en terme de de
gouvernance pour piloter de manière
efficace des projets structurants pour
notre audiovisuel
public tous ces tous ces chantiers sont
au cœur des des priorités de l'arcom
pour l'année à venir qui va être une
année de fortes
échéances ce sera mon dernier point
l'arcom va d'abord poursuivre son
engagement dans la mise en œuvre du
règlement européen sur les services
numériques c'est la nouvelle frontière
de la régulation j'en avais fait
personnellement la priorité de de mon
mandat vous vous le savez de faire en
sorte que cette autorité épouse son
temps et puisse s'investir pleinement
dans ce nouveau champ de la régulation
ce règlement européen sur les services
numériques le fameux DSA bien connu de
du Sénat est entré dans sa première
phase d'application pour les très
grandes plateformes le le 25 août
dernier il sera pleinement applicable
pour l'ensemble des des plateformes
concernées par ce texte le 17 février
prochain et c'est bien sûr un texte qui
étend et renouvelle profondément les
missission de l'autorité en matière de
supervision des des plateforme en ligne
il va renforcer très singulièrement
notre positionnement européen auprès de
la Commission européenne puisque la
gouvernance de ce règlement européen est
centré autour de la Commission
européenne en associant des autorités
nationales désignées par chaque pays
membre de l'Union et le projet de loi
porté par Monsieur barreau déjà voté au
Sénat voté à l'assemblée qui devrait
venir devant une commission mixte
paritaire lui aussi au début de l'année
prochaine devrait désigner l'arcom comme
autorité nationale pour pour la France
pour porter ces ces nouvelles
missions très attendu pour avoir un
Internet Plus Sûr pour porter ses
missions de équipes sont en cours de de
consolidation grâce aux moyens qui nous
ont été attribués en loi de finances
2023 et j'en remercie votre assemblée et
le Parlement dans son ensemble et ceux
qu'il est prévu de nous accorder dans le
projet de loi de finances pour
2024 et je le disais le projet de loi
visant à sécuriser et réguler l'espace
numérique quand il sera adopté donc
devrait désigner l'arcom comme
coordonateur coordinateur national pour
la France de ce texte au côté de laacnil
et de la direction générale de la de la
concurrence et c'est une responsabilité
à laquelle nous nous préparons
activement donc ça c'est un premier très
important chantier pour nous par
ailleurs plusieurs dossiers majeurs en
télévision et en radio figurent à notre
agenda pour pour les mois qui viennent
d'abord c'est un moment inédit dans
lequel nous sommes engagés vous savez
que les autorisations de 15 services de
la TNT nationale c'est une première dans
dans l'histoire de notre télévision
arrivveront à échéance en
2025 bien évidemment inutile de le
souligner un dossier à très fort enjeu
très fort enjeu pour le
secteur donc nous sommes d'ors et déjà
engagés dans ce
processus conformément à la loi nous
avons déjà mené une consultation
publique dont la synthèse sera rendue
publique dans les tous prochains
jour nous menons par ailleurs là aussi
conformément à la loi une étude d'impact
qui est en voie de de finalisation un
très gros travail je pense que votre
commission y trouvera beaucoup
d'informations très très riche très
intéressante sur l'état de la télévision
aujourd'hui en France donc cette étude
sera également rendue publique avant la
fin de cette de cette année le collège
l'adoptera très prochainement et nous
lancerons donc dans les premières
semaines de 2024 début 2024 un appel à
candidature pour
l'attribution des fréquences qui arrive
à
échéance j'ajoute en complément de ce de
cette petite présentation que le
gouvernement c'est une information
importante pour vous aussi a souhaité
que France Télévision puisse déployer
l'ultra haute définition donc est la
norme supérieure en terme de qualité
d'image de son
puisse déployer l'ultra haute définition
donc l'UHD à l'occasion des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 et
l'arcom chantier également important que
nous venons de mener qui est en cours a
autorisé donc ce déploiement de
l'ultraute
définition c'est tout tout récemment ces
derniers ces dernières semaines dans le
secteur de la radio que vous avez évoqué
monsieur le Président nous poursuivons
nos travaux pour étendre le DAB+
le livre blanc avance à grand pas nous
avons bien sûr terminé le cycle
d'audition de l'ensemble des des acteurs
nous sommes dans la phase de de
rédaction et comme je l'avais indiqué
nous rendrons les les conclusions de ce
livre blanc dans le courant du premier
trimestre 2000
2024 enfin un autre dossier d'ampleur
qui touche à notre souveraineté je sais
que vous êtes les uns et les autres très
sensibles et devant nous c'est celui des
services d'intérêts
généraux qui vise dans ce nouvel univers
des des téléviseurs que j'ai mentionné
rapidement tout à l'heure qui vise à
préserver la bonne
exposition de nos acteurs nationaux et
de leur programme dans le nouvel
environnement des des interfaces d'accès
au services audiovisuel là également
nous serons amenés à statuer dans les
toutes prochaines semaines la réflexion
de l'autorité après consultation des
acteurs et d'ors et déjà très
avancé sur tous ces sujets les états
généraux de l'information auquel LARCOM
entend contribuer vont être l'occasion
d'une réflexion transversale et
approfondie pour préparer l'avenir d'un
secteur qui est placé au cœur de notre
démocratie au cœur de la vie quotidienne
de nos
compatriotes les travaux menés à l'échon
européens notamment en matière
d'intelligence artificielle ou de
liberté des des médias contribueront
aussi à doter notre continent d'un d'un
cadre juridique adapté aux
transformations du moment car nous le
savons bien d' d'importantants défis
sont devant nous j'en citerai trois
seulement d'abord permettre à nos médias
nationaux de se doter d'un modèle
économique résiliant pour assurer leur
mission notamment celle de nous informer
alors que la situation internationale et
les défis que traversent nos sociétés
nécessitent plus que jamais une
information pluraliste honnête
indépendante rigoureuse qui contribue
pleinement à la formation des opinions
publiques et au débat
démocratiqu lutter aussi plus
efficacement contre la désinformation la
haine en ligne les ingérences étrangères
et les actions déstabilisatrices qu'un
bon auteur a qualifié ou a prêter aux
ingénieurs du chaos qui cible parfois
notre pays en tout cas notre continent
et ses valeurs et puis naturellement
protéger la liberté d'expression et le
pluralisme des médias dans un climat
nous l'observons tous de polarisation
extrême du débat et souvent
d'intolérance croissante en tout cas
soyez assurés que l'arcom est pleinement
mobilisé à la place qui est la sienne
sur l'ensemble de ces réflexions
stratégiques je vous remercie de votre
attention et me tiens naturellement à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions merci monsieur le Président
pour cette présentation très complète
déjà de à la fois de l'action 2023 de
l'arcom mais mais mais mais aussi des
des enjeux qui sont devant nous pour
l'année à venir sans plus tarder je cède
la parole à mes je donne la parole à mes
collègues en commençant par notre
rapporteur Cédric
Vial merci Messieurs les Présidents
euh merci beaucoup pour pour pour vos
propos qui étaient assez assez larg et
et assez précis moi j'aurais juste trois
questions mais qui sont assez assez
ciblées monsieur le Président euh la
première c'est concernant le les crédits
de l'audiovisuel public que nous avons
examiné la semaine dernière au au Sénat
le le gouvernement envisage entre 2024
et 2026 de faire bénéficier le secteur
de l'audiovisuel public de d'environ 200
millions d'euros pour financer des des
projet dans ce qu'on ce qu'il appelle
désormais des crédits de transformation
dans le cadre de des contrats
d'objectifs et et de moyens euh ce
versement de 200 millions d'euros pourra
être maintenu ou retiré si les résultats
obtenus ne sont pas conformes aux
objectifs de ces projets de
transformation qu'on qu'on ne connaît
pas encore au niveau du du Parlement euh
donc ma question était com comment ça
savez-vous comment seront évalués ces
résultats est-ce que vous allez
participer à l'évaluation des résultats
Quel rôle l'arcom va va jouer dans dans
ce cadre est-ce que l'arcom va formuler
également des les observations enfin
pardon l'arcom formule habituellement
des observations en général assez
mesurées sur l'exécution de de ces com
ces contrats d'objectifs et de moyens
comment allez va-t-on pouvoir traduire
ces observations en mesure financière
juste ou proportionn dans le le nouveau
cadre que le gouvernement souhaite poser
deuxème question concernant les les
états généraux de de l'information vous
en avez parlé un petit peu sur la fin de
votre intervention l'arcom a lancé une
étude sur l'avenir du marché marché
publicitaire euh ce marché se déplace
progressivement vers le numérique enfin
progressivement c'est un euphémisme
notamment vers les moteurs de recherche
et les réseaux sociaux au détriment des
des médias et du véritable travail
journalistique est-ce que cette étude de
l'arcom pourrait aboutir d'après vous
sur des recommandations d'ordre
législatif ou réglementaire pour définir
de nouveaux équilibres sur les marchés
publicitaires euh alors que les acteurs
entrant ne sont pas soumis vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure aux mêmes contraintes
que le les acteurs du secteur historique
et enfin ma dernière question quel est
votre regard sur la bataille
informationnelle qui se joue dans le
domaine de l'audiovisuel comme dans
celui du numérique alors que le contexte
international est aujourd'hui
extrêmement tendu le risque d'ingérence
étrangère est particulièrement élevé
dans la perspective des Jeux Olympiques
les médias sont également des cibles
potentielles de cyberattaque les fausses
informations et les narratifs
alternatifs éventuellement propagés par
des puisances étrangères S semble de
moins en moins
maîtrisable comment pensez-vous pouvoir
traiter cette question et disposez-vous
de moyens suffisants je n'ai pas cité
l'intelligence artificielle mais ça
pourrait également être une une
dominante de de cette dernière question
voilà je vous remercie monsieur le
Président je vais vous laisser répondre
aux questions du
rapporteur merci monsieur le rapporteur
pour ces trois trois questions sur
l'audiovisuel
publ même si le
reprendre votre expression même si
l'autorité le fait de façon mesurée
c'est sa nature je dirais
euh il formule ses observations
néanmoins avec conviction euh et dans
les avis que nous avons pu rendre sur
l'exécution des contrats d'objectifs et
de moyen du du service public ou sur le
respect du du cahier des charges des
entreprises du service public nous avons
à plusieurs reprises souligner des
points qui nous semblent importants pour
l'échéance qui est devant nous celle des
des contrats d'objectif en cours de
d'élaboration et et nous sommes comm
comme vous encore dans un climat
d'incertitude puisque nousons pas eu
communication LARCOM rendra en temps et
heure son son avis sur ces projets nous
avons toujours souligné des point qui
nous paraissent essentiel il y a il y a
aujourd'hui comme pour les acteurs
privés des enjeux décisifs pour pour le
service public la question du
rajunissement de ces publics un enjeu
majeur je cité l'âge moyen du
téléspectateur sur le service public on
peut pas se satisfaire qu'un service
public qui doit s'adresser à tous les
Français ne touche pas davantage les les
jeunes public l'offre de proximité on le
voit bien au moment où les acteurs
privés déploient des initiatives pour
être plus présents dans les territoires
l'offre de service public doit à
l'évidence être rénovée modernisé
concentré pour être plus plus efficace
la stratégie numérique des groupes du
service public doit bien évidemment être
rassemblé unifié je rappelle que notre
pays est singulier c'est le seul pays
pratiquement en Europe où le service
public soit éclaté dans tous les pays
européens le service public est
rassemblé en Angleterre en Italie euh
dans pratiquement tous les pays de tous
les pays de l'Union et je pense que
cette idée
euh du du rassemblement des forces qui
est porté euh du côté du secteur privé
euh euh doit être considéré avec
attention pour euh pour le service
public aussi et de ce point de vue-là
euh l'arcom fait deux observations sur
sur le financement nous sommes très
attachés à un financement dédié au
service public que nous considérons
comme une condition de son indépendance
et du financement des nombreuses
missions particulières qui lui qui lui
incombent
actuellement il y a une
solution transitoire qui a été mise en
œuvre qui est celle d' d'un prélèvement
d'une fraction de TVA pour se substituer
à l'ancienne contribution à
l'audiovisuel
publ c'est pas quels sont les les
modalités que le gouvernement retiendra
dans dans ses propositions pour 2025
mais cette option la pérénisation de
cette option nous paraîtrait une
solution de nature à répondre à ce
besoin de garantie d'indépendance et la
deè observation
je l'ai évoqué à propos de deux dossiers
qui sont à mes yeux emblématiques France
Info et le rapprochement de de France 3
France Bleue c'est des enjeux très
importants France 3 France Bleue
schématiquement c'est un/ers des
effectifs de chacune des entreprises
c'est c'est de des réseaux des réseaux
très significatifs le le succès de ces
convergences le succès de ces
rapprochement ne pourra pas être laissé
à la seule bonne volonté des partis il
faut arriver à trouver une forme de
gouvernance qui permette de porter ces
projets il faut un pilote dans l'avion
pour employer une une formule en tout
cas pour piloter ces ces deux projets
très très
structurants de ce point de vue-là le
gouvernement envisage donc de dans dans
son financement de déployer une une
dotation spécifique pour accompagner les
projets de transformation vous l'avez
évoqué cette dotation de de 200 millions
d'euros qui serait libéré par tranche en
fonction de de de la mesure des des
résultats atteints au regard d'objectif
qui serait fixé dans le contrat une
mission a été confiée à l'Inspection
Générale des Finances qui est en cours
de travail avec les entreprises de
l'audiovisuel et dont les conclusions
seront semble-t-il connues au début de
l'année prochaine qui permettrai
d'identifier
précisément les objectifs d'une part les
indicateurs de mesures qui permettrai
d'apprécier année après année l'atteinte
de ces de ces résultats l'arcom est bien
évidemment tout à fait prêt dans les
avis annuels qu'elle rend sur
l'exécution des contrats d'objectif a
joué son rôle dans l'examen de ces
indicateurs annuels qui conditionneraiit
la la
libération de de la tranche annuelle de
de
soutien mais elle soulignera dans son
avis qu'il est essentiel que les
indicateurs permettent effectivement de
mesurer les prog réalisé chaque année
donc ça suppose d'avoir vraiment des
indicateurs précis des objectifs
attendus chaque année dans ces projets
de de rapprochement en
particulier sur les états généraux de de
l'information l'arcom bien évidemment va
va y participer je serai auditionné
moi-même par le comité de pilotage des
des États généraux début de début de
l'année prochaine au titre de notre
contribution nous avons lancé de deux
études importantes l'une sur les
Français l'information qui je crois sera
sera très riche pour pour nous tous même
si il y a déjà eu des des des travaux
menés en la matière mais c'est êre une
étude très très complète avec un panel
un panel extrêmement large et qui
permettra d'avoir un regard très très
précis très complet sur la façon dont
dont dont les Français expriment leurs
attentes en matière de d'information et
puis cette étude que vous avez évoqué
qui sera prête je pense dans le courant
du mois de janvier ou milieu du mois de
janvier j'espère sur la publicité c'est
une étude qu'on mène conjointement avec
les services du du ministère de la
Culture qui est aussi intéressé et ça
devrait permettre on en connaît
déjà les pr les prés résultats
d'objectiver d'objectiver les tendances
de fond de ce marché et les enjeux qui
en résultent pour chacune des familles
de de médias et l'idée c'est bien
évidemment de venir nourrir la réflexion
et des
propositions pour soutenir le modèle
économique de nos médias je pense que au
cœur des états généraux de l'information
c'est comment assure-t-on le modèle
économique de l'ensemble de nos médias
pour les années qui viennent en matière
de presse écrite de radio de de
télévision
euh probablement qu'il y a des points au
regard des des asymétries entre les
acteurs du numérique et les acteurs
traditionnels où il faudra faire évoluer
la la la réglementation en tout cas
l'objet de cette étude c'est de donner
une base commune de réflexion objective
un constat objectif euh pour que chacun
puisse ensuite prendre les
recommandations les propositions et les
décisions qui qui
s'impose la bataille informationnelle et
c'est bien évidemment un enjeu central
aujourd'hui les ingérence
étrangèr je pense qu'elles exigent elles
vont exiger en tout cas pour l'année
2024 à mon sens euh une vigilance
extrême euh les élections européennes on
le voit bien dans le
contexte géopolitique du continent mais
pas
seulement peuvent inciter certains
acteurs à vouloir peser sur le
déroulement de ce scrutin au sein des
différents pays de de l'Union donc la
France c'est dotée vous le savez d'un
service à compétence nationale viginum
qui est placé auprès du secrétaire
général de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale qui est destiné à à lutter
précisément contre contre les ingérences
étrangères l'arcom au titre de ses
compétences en matière de lutte contre
la manipulation de l'information et au
titre des relations étroites qu'elle
entretient avec les les plateformes
numériques du fait de s ses compétences
est associé à la gouvernance de de
viginum j'ai eu l'occasion de d'échanger
avec le secrétaire général de de la
défense il y a pas très longtemps et
donc on se prépare d'ors et déjà à
l'organisation de de ce
scrutin je voudrais souligner quand
quand en 2022 pour le scrutin
présidentiel et pour les législatives
nous avions réuni l'ensemble des
plateformes numériques dès le mois de
janvier et nous avons échangé avec elle
grosso modo tous les 15 jours pendant
toute la phase électorale et que sur
tous ces sujets de de manipulation
d'information nous avons eu une
collaboration très positive de leur part
toutes ces plateformes maintenant sont
sont rompu à ces processus électoraux
avec l'expérience des des scrutins
américains d'élection générales qui se
sont déroulés dans dans toute une série
de de pays elles mettent en place au
moment des élections des des cellules
spécifiques pour suivre ces ces sujets-l
et donc on on veillera bien évidemment à
être très attentif au sujet de à ces
sujets de de manipulation de de
l'information de de façon plus générale
au regard de votre question je l'évoqué
dans mon dans mon propos
introductif je pense qu'il est très
important d'accompagner nos acteurs
traditionnels et et de veiller à la
soutenabilité de leur modèle finan parce
que
l'information coûte cher une information
professionnelle avec des rédactions qui
vérifient l'information qui la
contrôle c'est c'est un coût très
important et donc si on veut assurer au
français une information indépendante
pluraliste rigoureuse honnête ça suppose
d'avoir des médias pluralistes des
médias correctement financés et je crois
qu'on est dans une période où faut être
très attentif précisément à leur modèle
économique ça vaut pour le service
public je l'ai dit c'est pour ça que ces
conditions de financement sont
importantes mais ça vaut pour nos pour
nos médias privé vous m'aveiez interrogé
monsieur le Président sur le conflit du
Proche Orient j'ai eu l'occasion de
réunir l'ensemble des des
rédactions des médias publics et privés
de notre de notre
pays qui nous ont fait part des des
difficultés qu'il rencontrait dans la
couverture de ces de ces
événements difficulté dans l'accès à
l'information bien évidemment c'est
qu'il y a des territoires sur lesquels
la présence des correspondants est un
vrai sujet la difficulté de de
vérification du coup des informations
pour qu'elle puisse être délivrée avec
sûreté avec avec
certitude on a observer et le régulateur
a été amené et sera encore amené à
intervenir sur quelques médias on a pu
observer ici ou là quelques dérapages
euh mais le vrai sujet là aussi c'est
quand même sur la sphère numérique
qu'elle se pose les vrais dérapages
qu'on a observé c'est bien sur les
réseaux sociaux et vous savez qu'au
titre du Règlement sur les services
numériques la Commission européenne
Thierry Breton le commissaire européen
s'est exprimé à plusieurs reprises
là-dessus la Commission européenne a
engagé des premières actions au titre du
règlement européen à l'égard notamment
de de X successeur de de
Twitter pour une éventuelle noncformité
au règ du DSA au regard de la nature de
certains contenus qu'on a qu'on a pu
circuler de façon viralisée sur ces sur
ces plateformes j'espère avoir répondu à
vos questions monsieur le rapporteur
alors je vais prendre l'ensemble de vos
questions en commençant par Max
[Musique]
BR merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président d'abord à mon tour de vous
remercier de votre tableau très précis
très
didactique ce que vous avez déjà dans le
passé appelé la la triple évolution qui
menace la télévision traditionnelle il y
a un an lors de vos vœux de
l'installation de l'arcom et depuis de
manière récurrente vous rappelez qu'une
des ambitions de l'arcom est de
favoriser le dynamisme de nos acteurs
nationaux face à la concurrence mondiale
et vous venez encore de le rappeler
au-delà d'éditeur comme TF1 ou M6 il
s'agit de défendre l'ensemble de
l'écosystème audiisuel français au sein
duquel les distributeurs comme les
fournisseurs d'accès à Internet ou Canal
Plus plus joue un rôle central or si on
peroitement en quoi soutenir la
transformation des producteurs des
chaînes de télévision et de
l'audiovisuel public est essentiel tant
il concourt à notre souveraineté
économique et culturelle il demeure je
crois un angle mort qui restreint notre
compréhension de l'écosystème je parlais
du rôle des distributeurs de services de
télévision déclarés auprès de l'arcom
dans la valorisation et la diffusion de
programmes originaux face aux
télévisions connecté
eux aussi sont déstabilisés par ces
nouveaux acteurs et subissent de plein
fouet ces mutations pourtant à travers
leurs partenariat avec les étiteurs ces
opérateurs protègent l'accès la
visibilité des chaînes françaises face à
la concurrence internationale si nous
souhaitons que le public continue à
bénéficier d'une offre diversifiée les
dist les distributeurs nationaux doivent
être favorisé au même titre que les
services de la TNT c'est un enjeu de
souveraineté culturel conformément à la
mission qui lui a été confiée par la loi
l'arcom travaille actuellement vous
l'avez dit sur la mise à avant des
services dit d'intérêt général le
législateur ayant limité ses services
aux seuls acteurs du service public dans
votre réflexion qui semble sur point
d'aboutir avez-vous pris en compte le
rôle central des distributeurs nationaux
dans l'accessibilité au du public au
service français face à la concurrence
des opérateurs étrangers qui n'y seront
pas soumis une régulation supp aire ne
risque-elle pas d'affaiblir une nouvelle
fois les distributeurs nationaux et donc
de porter atteinte à notre souveraineté
culturelle ne Fazil pas que la France
fasse évoluer la législation pour
imposer à des services identiques les
mêmes obligations que celle qui income
au distributeurs nationaux ne
fautrait-il pas enfin le cas échéant
pousser dans le sang d'une évolution du
droit communautaire pour reconnaître les
acteurs connectés comme des
distributeurs à partentière je vous
remercie mer Sylvie
Robert merci monsieur le Président euh
monsieur le Président vous l'avez dit en
2024 l'arcom va donc lancer un appel à
candidature pour le renouvellement de 15
fréquences donc lesquels arriveront à
échéance 2025 dans le contexte que nous
connaissons marqué par la très forte
concurrence entre les groupes
audiovisuel par les stratégies de
consolidation mais aussi par l'intérêt
croissant des plateformes numériques
pour le canal TV
cette procédure d'autorisation revête de
mon point de vue un enjeu considérable
j'ajouteraiis vous l'avez aussi
souligner que cette procédure ne s'est
jamais déroulé dans un climat politique
et
informationnel ça je le je le pense
vraiment aussi polarisé aussi détérioré
peut-être même source de tension de
polémique pour le dire simplement votre
mission s'annonce très délicate alors en
matière d'information nous avons
constaté vous l'avez fait à plusieurs
reprises monsieur le Président de grav
et répétés manquement au plusal
et de manière générale aux obligations
déontologiques qui figurent dans les
conventions que vous signez avec les
chaînes autorisées à diffuser je cite un
alinéa que j'ai pris dans une convention
assez intéressante qui cite bien sûr le
respect des différentes sensibilité
politique culturelle et religieuse du
public qui demande de promouvoir les
valeurs d'intégration et de solidarité
qui sont celles de la République et à
lutter contre les discriminations et
cetera dans certains clans emblématiques
alors que la convention précise que le
est consacré à l'information nous avons
constaté une le glissade vers la
diffusion d'opinion toujours identique
allant à l'encontre du principe de
pluralisme et du traitement
déontologique de
l'information Monsieur le Président
analysez-vous ainsi aussi cette tendance
et dans le casadre de la future
procédure de renouvellement des
fréquences envisagez-vous de muscler les
conventions signées avec les chaînes
d'information afin d'éviter qu'elle ne
se transforme en médias
d'opinion deuxème euh question qui
portera sur le Daap plus elle pardon
laissez finir je continue je vous
remercie qui ma dernière question va
porter sur le Daap plus et notamment sur
son déploiement équilibré dans les
territoires euh je cite un exemple en
Bretagne seul 25 radios associatifs sur
32 vont basculer en Daap
plus autrement dit les les auditeurs
bretons et notamment ceux des zones
rurales vont être confrontés à une
diminution de l'offre est-ce que la
stratégie de l'arcom va être vraiment
pour essayer de déployer de façon
équilibrée le DAB dans les territoires
même de créer puisque j'ai la demande
aussi de de d'obtention de fréquence
pour une radio notamment en langue
régionale et est-ce que il est prévu de
renforcer l'accompagnement des radios
associatives qui est diffus encore en FM
et en dapus pour les pour prendre en
compte bien sûr les coûts induits par
cette double diffusion et enfin une
observation vous avez cité mais pas
complètement je voudrais avoir votre
avis on observe un mouvement croisé où
les télés vous l'avez dit ce
plateformise alors c'est pas un terme
très mais où les plateforme se télévise
je sais pas comment dire et à la fois
sur le plan des contenus mais aussi sur
la forme avec la pub je trouve que c'est
une tendance qui est quand même assez
forte et qui va probablement être aussi
pour vous peut-être un laboratoire
d'observation où il y aura des
conséquences pour l'arcom donc j'avais
envie aussi d'avoir votre avis sur cette
tendance merci Monsieur Catherine main
de saill qui je le rappelle préside
également la la Commission spéciale sur
le projet de loi visant à sécuriser
l'espace numérique merci Monsieur le le
président euh tout d'abord je voudrais
poser la question suivante à rocovell MS
c'est que devant la démultiplication des
missions qui sont conférées à l'arcom
laquelle a fusionné CSA à doopi déjà une
première étape mais en application du
fameux RSN et depuis la loi visant à
lutter contre la manipulation de la
formation vos missions sont
démultipliées jugez-vous à l'ône des
crédit qui ont été votés pour cette
année cette loi de finance 2024 que vous
disposez des moyens suffisants et aussi
des compétences et qu'il est facile de
recruter aujourd'hui les compétences
dont vous avez besoin ça c'est ma
première question ma deuxème question
complète celle de notre rapporteur
Cédric Vial en tout cas en son
prolongement vous avez monsieur le
Président dit que la meilleure façon
d'armer somme toute notre audiovisuel
face à la désinformation c'est lui
garantir suffisamment de moyens pour
pouvoir euh travailler dans le cadre de
la Présidence française de l'Union
européenne Avaz été tenu et vous y aviez
participé des États généraux avec
l'ensemble des audiovisuels publics
européens et et je crois savoir qu' la
tribune les uns et les autres don
vous-même s'était exprimé justement sur
la nécessaire euh euh non budgétisation
c'estàdire l'indépendance des médias à
travers une ressource affectée et donc
bien une dotation publique et non une
dotation d'État pouvez-vous préciser
votre propos de de de de l'époque qui
garantit l'autonomie de de l'audiovisuel
publque sur les écrans vous avez aussi
fait état de la la préservation de la
bonne exposition des écrans je sais que
vous meniez va emmener avec Carole
Bienaimé B qui a quitté le CSA tout un
travail sur l'exposition des très jeunes
au écrans vous savez qu'un un texte de
loi a été voté à unanuitité à partir de
notre commission quelques années visant
à encadrer l'exposition des tout petits
des moins de 3 ans un texte similaire
d'ailleurs a été voté à l'initiative de
la députée Caroline janvier à
l'Assemblée nationale mais il ne se sont
pas encore pour l'instant retrouvés
pouvez-vous nous dire ce que vous
concrètement vous vous faites et les
problèmes que vous rencontrez par
rapport à la protection de ces de ces
tout petits en attente d'une législation
euh s'agissant de l'application du DSA
sur lequel nous nous travaillons en
effet au sein de la commission spéciale
sécurisé réguli espace numérique dont
plusieurs membres de cette commission
sont
également membres nous sommes préoccupés
par plusieurs points le texte est
d'ailleurs dans la navette en attente
des notifications de de Bruxelles euh
depuis lors euh on a forcément été très
attentif à l'arrêt de la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne du 9 novembre qui
semble gravement mettre en cause toute
possibilité d'imposer au niveau national
des obligations aux plateformes euh or
l'arcom à travers euh les textes déjà
adoptés j'ai cité la loi visant à lutter
contre la manipulation de l'information
mais je vrais citer la loi majorité
numérique ou d'autres textes à venir
précisément comme le sren euh tout ça
c'est au cœur de la régulation nationale
quelle est votre analyse et surtout euh
selon vous les conséquences pour euh
pour votre autorité de de de régulation
euh un sujet éalement le fait que
l'Assemblée nationale a choisi pour ce
projet de loi sen de revenir au texte
initial sur les articles 1 et 2 qui
instaure un contrôle de l'accès au site
pornographique donc cela se traduit par
une absence de coordination entre le
contrôle du respect du référentiel
établi par l'arcom par vos soins donc à
l'article 1er et les sanctions pénales à
l'article 2 pardonnez-moi chers collègu
de ces questions un peu techniques mais
es sont essentielles que pensez-vous de
cette évolution et y voyez-vous un
risque de fragilis
du dispositif avenir voilà et enfin
comment concevez-vous votre rôle de
coordinateur des services numériques en
application du DSN qui est prévu à
l'article 25 du 10 projet de loi je vous
remercie Monique de
Marc je vous remercie certaines
questions ont été posées je vais
compléter monsieur le Président voilà
cette semaine j'ai lu un rapport donc de
la Fédération internationale des
industries
phonographique qui soulligne le fait que
il y a 27 % de personnes interrogées qui
utilisent les méthodes illégales ou sans
licence pour écouter au télécharger de
la musique l'arcom ne doit-il pas
renforcer sa surveillance quelle
pourrait être son rôle justement parce
que cette recrud d'esence a l'air de de
s'imposer ensuite j'ai une question au
point de vue national comment
anticipez-vous l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle au sein des
rédactions audiovisuelles par exemple et
une deuxième question qui rejoint un peu
des interrogations sur le plan européen
comment envisagez-vous votre nomination
certaine pour
l'erga comme régulateur sur la liberté
de la presse en France sachant que cela
semble être en contradiction avec son
histoire pierre
ouas merci Monsieur le le président
merci pour la la qualité de de votre
propos et ce et ce bilan tout à fait
intéressant comme j'arrive en fin de de
et seulement moi j'aimerais reprendre la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
qui me semble tout à fait
fondamentale le Parlement européen a
défini quelques grands objectifs pour
une future législation dont on connaît
pas aujourd'hui exactement quel pourrait
être le le périmètre précis il est à
noter que le gouvernement français de
façon assez singulière s'est opposé à
une législation dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle un ancien
ministre monsieur Cédrico ayant même
développé une campagne très active pour
expliquer que merci pour expliquer que
ça serait contraire au aux intérêts de
la France que de réglementer
l'intelligence
artificienne pourtant vous avez déjà une
action qui est très forte sur les les
algorithmes et la commission d'enquête
du
Sénat a montré combien s'agissant du cas
particulier de TikTok ces algorithmes
pouvaient être toxiques et euh on
imagine bien que si vous doublez ces
algorithmes avec de l'intelligence
artificielle on peut arriver à des
choses où euh il y a plus de contrôle
humain dans la production de ce qui est
essentiel aujourd'hui pour l'information
c'est-à-dire l'image et dans un conflit
comme ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui on
voit très bien euh ce que pourrait
être l'impact d'image construite par
l'intelligence euh artificielle donc
c'est sur ce point que j'im aimais vous
vous interroger pour voir quel est votre
niveau de de réflexion et après demande
très technique est-ce que vous pourriez
si si si si vous le connaissez nous
préciser de façon plus précise le
calendrier exact du renouvellement des
chaînes de de la TNT merci monsieur le
Président anque
billon merci monsieur le Président merci
à vous monsieur le Président également
euh je voudrais revenir sur les travaux
de la délégation au droit des femmes sur
la pornographie et puis comme j'ai à
côté de moi une des rapporteurs je pense
qu'elle reviendra aussi sur le sujet on
le sait 2 tiers des enfants de moins de
12 ans ont accès à des images
pornographiques un/ers un/ers des
enfants de moins de 12 ans et 2/3 des
enfants de moins de 15 ans la
pornographie c'est l'exploitation
commerciale de la représentation
explicite et filmé de pratiques
sexuelles non simulé alors je voudrais
dans ce cadre euh revenir
sur des contenus les contenus frenchy
Shore et qui qui finalement tombe
largement sous sous cette définition je
sais que le président Gérard Larcher et
le président Laffond ont été assez
sensibilisés à ce sujet et je
peut-être vous poser quelques questions
à ce sujet
euh on a eu on avec le projet de Douine
pardon je suis un peu malade enrumé
excusez-moi ça raisonne dans le nez avec
le projet de loi numérique et à
l'instant Maine de sayli est revenu
dessus nous avons vu les difficultés à
appliquer la loi pour interdire l'accès
des mineurs à ces contenus alors pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas trop le
contenu des de cette cette téléréalité
qui a été lancé en France en de en
novembre 2023 je voudrais dire que ces
contenus frenchy Shore ils sont
accessibles sur les plateformes MTV et
Paramount c'est des contenus avec un
accès payant mais en réalité ils sont
relayés largement sur les rése RX
sociaux et donc accessible à tous
globalement il y a un message qui est de
prévention au départ mais finalement
comme ils sont relayés sur les réseaux
sociaux ils sont accessibles à tous les
mineurs très facilement il est question
de d'agression sexuel puisqu'il y a
défaut de consentement dans certains
contenus il est question d'actes sexuel
et donc la ministre de la Culture a
estimé que les missions était finalement
avec des contenu pornographique et
qu'elle souhaitait des mesures de la
part de
l'arcom donc la ministre de la Culture
vous a finalement demander de réguler
cette téléréalité et à cette à cette
demande je vous avez répondu l'arcom a
répondu semble-t-il que vous n'étiez pas
compétent puisque les plateformes qui
hébergent ces
sites ne sont pas installées en ces
émissions pardon ne sont pas installées
en France c'est normalement au rég Atur
du pays
d'implantation qui doit agir qui est
compétent pour agir l'arcom ne peut
intervenir sur les contenus des services
de streaming internationaux donc dans le
cas de MTV France et paramont plus
l'éditeur du premier é en basé à Prague
et le second à Berlin seuls les
régulateurs tchqus ou Allemands peuvent
intervenir c'est donc ce que vous portez
comme réponse auprès de la ministre de
la Culture donc vous alertez d'ailleurs
vos homologues sur les vives réactions
qui ont suscité ces ces contenus à la
fois dans l'Hexagone et vous pointez des
interrogations quant au au aux objectifs
d'une part du respect de la protection
de la dignité humaine et d'autre part de
la protection des mineurs qui évidemment
n'est pas garanti dans ce cas-là donc
euh d'un côté nous avons la ministre de
la Culture qui dit que vous êtes
compétent de l'autre côté l'arcom dit
que vous n'êtes pas compétent donc moi
je voudrais juste vous poser une
question simple monsieur le président
euh que faut-il pour que vous soyez
compétent pour pouvoir réguler ces
contenus je vous remercie merci
Marie-Pierre
Monier merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues alors d'abord je
m'associe aux questions donc du coup ça
sera qu'une remarque sur les moyens dont
vous allez disposer parce que vous avez
bien égrainé tout un nombre de missions
supplémentaires que vous avez exercé
vous avez parlé de 200 millions qui
allaiit vous être alloué par tranche
mais vous avez aussi spécifié que il y
avait des objectifs bien précis et qu'il
faudrait bien contrôler que les
objectifs sont atteints donc je je
rejoins au fond la question de de mes
collègues précédemment euh je m'associe
à celle de d'anck également parce que je
suis membre de la délégation droits des
femmes et les remarques qu'elle a pu
vous faire font suite à un rapport qui
qui a eu un grand retentissement et
surtout qui a pointé de de grandes
problématiques justement je crois que
par rapport à ce que vous avez précisé
tout à l'heure sur le projet de loi
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
euh la version UE de l'Assemblée
nationale prévoit que l'arcom aura 2
mois pour élaborer un référentiel
général fixant les exigences techniques
auxquelles devront se confronter les
systèmes de vérification d'âge des sites
pornographiques prévus par le texte moi
j'aimerais que vous reveniez sur ce
délai me
disiez que vous puissiez me dire si
vraiment vous pensez que ce c est
suffisant
merci
fon monsieur le Président de l'arcom je
voudrais vous interroger donc sur
l'expérimentation qui est actuellement
menée sur les sites pornographiques est
censé d'ailleurs suivre l'une des
recommandation des de notre rapport
publié maintenant il y a 18 mois pourn
l'enfer du decor qu' rédigé notamment
par ma collègue et voisine et malade an
nique billon
euh pas la
COV en mars dernier donc un avis de
LARCOM je le rappelle avait défini le
principe du double anonyma je cite comme
le stème le plus robuste non seulement
pour résoudre une bonne fois pour toutes
la question de la vérification d'âge sur
les sites porno mais éventuellement à
l'avenir pour effectuer d'autres
vérification d'âge nous sommes tous ici
en tout cas conscients que ce système
opérant de
vérification les avancé législative en
tout cas voté demeure malheureusement
veine et donc sans véritable effet dans
la pratique lors du même mois de mars le
ministre Barot avait d'ailleurs indiqué
au députés de la délégation au droits
des enfants que le site de devait
réaliser une telle expérimentation afin
évidemment de protéger nos mineurs de
ces contenus inappropriés de fait je
souhaiterais donc savoir si vous aviez
des éléments relatifs au résultats de
ces premières expérimentations à nos
communiqués parce que il y a vraiment
aucune information là-dessus et je
voulais aussi vous interroger sur celle
menée récemment par Docapost qui est une
filiale numérique du groupe la poost qui
vient juste d'annoncer he je crois que c
en date du 10 novembre une
expérimentation d'une solution pour
garantir enfin véritablement l'anonymat
des internautes et protéger les mineurs
je remerci pierreanttoine l oui merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur le
présidentarc pour pour le le détail de
vos propos et sur le rapport
d'information alors plusieurs questions
que je voulais posé ont été ont été posé
notamment par ma collègue Annique billon
donc je voulais savoir effectivement sur
les émissions controversi comme
frenchort quels sont les limites les
compétences de l'arcom dans la
régulation de ce type de contenu est-ce
que vous pouvezous également nous
détailler comment l'arcom équilibre la
liberté d'expression et la nécessité de
modérer des contenus potentiellement
offensants ou discriminatoire je pense
au sketch de Guillaume meurce sur Radio
France sur lequel vous avez fait des des
remarques bien évidemment et ensuite je
av une question concernant la l'annonce
par TF1 de la du lancement le 8 janvier
de la matinale matinale qui va venir
concurrencer différentes matinales qui
existent sur une offre qui est déjà
largement qui est très importante je
voulais savoir quand vous avez renouvelé
la licence de TF1 il y a quelques mois
est-ce que vous étiez au courant ou
est-ce que vous avez été informé de
cette annonce et quel est votre avis en
tant que régulateur sur le lancement de
cette
matinale
prochainement Laurence
Garnier merci monsieur le Président
merci au président de l'arcom pour pour
ses propos vous avez rappelé monsieur le
Président plusieurs fois dans votre
intervention la nécessité que nous
partageons tous ici de médias honnêtes
pluralistes indépendants dans un monde
où là aussi vous l'avez rappelé la
désinformation circule parfois plus vite
que l'information elle-même moi je crois
beaucoup au rôle de nos
médias pour aider nos concitoyens à
forger une pensée complexe dans un monde
où on peut regretter que n'est souvent
voix au chapitre que les propos simples
voire parfois simplistes donc dans ce
contexte l'arcom joue pleinement son
rôle pour canalyser ce paysage
médiatique dans un environnement qui est
compliqué au niveau national on le
mesure actuellement avec tous les débats
liés à la loi immigration et aussi bien
sûr au niveau international avec le
conflit
israélo-palestinien je crois avoir lu
monsieur le Président que l'arcom avait
été saisi de nombreuses fois depuis le
début de ce conflit
israélo-palestinien avec euh un certain
nombre de décisions que vous avez été
amené à prendre qui vont de la mise en
garde à la saisie de rapporteur
indépendant en vue d'éventuelles
sanctions les décisions que vous prenez
vous le mesurez sont à la fois euh euh
commenté reprises par les médias
eux-mêmes et peuvent parfois générer des
interrogations des incompréhension de la
part de nos concitoyens avec finalement
le sujet de savoir ce qui relève mon
collègue Pierre-Antoine léville a dit à
l'instant de la liberté d'exprimer une
opinion qui bien sûr peut ne pas plaire
à tout le monde d'exprimer une analyse
un propos choquant un propos
humoristique ou en tout cas qui se
revendique comme tel donc est-ce que
vous pourriez monsieur le Président nous
redonner ce matin la hiérarchie des
sanctions de l'arcom que l'arcom
peut-être amené à prononcer et aussi
nous éclairer sur les critères qui
président à vos prises de
décision je vais rajouter une question à
la liste de celle déjà posée concernant
le le renouvellement des autorisations
euh comment prendrez-vous en compte les
sanctions qu'a pu prendre l'arcom ces
dernières années sur des bénéficiaires
des autorisations avec les les
renouvellements ou pas que vous aurez à
procéder dans quelques
mois merci monsieur le Président merci
euh madame la sénatrice et Messieurs les
les sénateurs je vais m'efforcer de
répondre à toutes ces questions je pe
peut-être commencer
par la dernière les dernières questions
qui m'ont été posées finalement
sur l'équilibre que que
l'autorité doit assurer entre la liberté
de communication et la protection des
publics et la façon dont elle est amenée
à
intervenir quand c'est nécessaire auprès
auprès des
éditeurs je rappellerai d'abord que que
le champ dans lequel on intervient c'est
celui d'une liberté publique
fondamentale qui est celui de la liberté
de de communication de la liberté
d'expression c'est un principe dans
notre pays de nature constitutionnelle
vous le savez il est
consubstantiel à notre démocratie
renvoie très directement à l'article 11
de la Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyens de
1789 l'un des biens le plus précieux de
l'humanité dit cet article
et ce droit cette liberté fondamentale
est bien évidemment extrêmement protégée
dans notre droit il est protégé par la
Constitution il est protégé par nos lois
et il est protégé par nos juridictions
nationales et européennes la loi que
nous mettons en œuvre à
l'arcom il faut toujours le répéter est
d'abord une loi de liberté elle
s'appelle loi relative à la liberté de
communication c'est le pendant pour le
champ audiovisuel de la loi 18 181 sur
la liberté de la presse et son article 1
rappelle que la communication est libre
et c'est par exception à ce principe
horizontal fondamental que le
législateur puisque seul le législateur
peut le faire a poser un certain nombre
de limites que les éditeurs euh de
programme de télévision ou de radio sont
tenu de respecter donc ce sont des
obligations qui s'imposent à eux qui
sont posées par la loi
ou le règlement ou par les conventions
que nous sommes amenés à conclure avec
eux au moment de la délivrance des
autorisations ça veut dire que d'abord
l'autorité n'intervient jamais bien
évidemment a priori sur des programmes
de télévision ou de radio c'est une
évidence mais il faut le rappeler ici
l'arcom n'est bien évidemment pas une
autorité de censure elle n'assure pas
une police de la pensée les programmes
sont diffusés librement et sous leur
responsabilité par les éditeurs mais ils
engagent le cas échéant leur
responsabilité si ces programmes les
contenus qu'ils diffusent sont en
infraction avec la loi ou avec les
textes conventionnels ou les recom les
délibérations que que l'arcom peut être
amené à
prendre sur chacune des alertes qui nous
est adressé quotidiennement c'est une
chose facile à faire il y a un bouton
sur le site de l'arcom et en une minute
une minute et demi
on peut nous saisir sur un programme qui
qui HETE qui qui choque pour reprendre
votre expression madame madame la
sénatrice nous conduisons une
instruction approfondie ces séquences
sont revisionnées parce qu'alors des
réseaux sociaux l'expérience montre que
bien souvent nous sommes saisis sur des
morceaux tronqués d'une séquence et dès
que vous la remettez en perspective ell
prennent un sens naturellement différent
donc il faut toujours reprendre la
séquence dans son ensemble pour
s'assurer exact de ce qui a été dit ou
ou montré nous menons une analyse
juridique très approfondie et je
rappelle qu'on a maintenant 40 ans de
jurisprudence derrière nous puisque la
la régulation audiovisuelle a grosso
modo 40 ans de d'histoire donc le
Conseil d'État a très très souvent
statué sur les décisions que l'ancien
CSA l'arcom maintenant peut être amené à
prendre et donc notre notre ligne
d'intervention elle est très balisée à
la fois par la loi mais aussi par le
juge puisque tout nos décisions sont
susceptibles de recours contentieux et
et d'annulation possible par par le
Conseil d'État donc on sait la ligne de
crête qu'on doit tenir c'est une ligne
de crête qui est bien évidemment
délicate c'est la raison pour laquelle
toutes nos décisions sans exception sont
des décisions collégiales donc à chaque
réunion du collège chaque mercredi on
examine un certain nombre de saisines
que nous avons reçu au cours des des
semaines écoulé et cette délibération
débouche donc sur nos positions je
rappelle que dans notre collège euh on a
plusieurs magistrats on a un membre du
Conseil d'État on a magistrat de la Cour
de cassation on a quelques juristes
émérites au-delà de la compétence très
forte des services en la matière et donc
on est toujours sur cette ligne de crête
est-on dans le champ de la
liberté ce qui justifie que le
régulateur n'intervienne pas ou en tout
cas n'interviennent pas dans une
procédure de de de de de sanction de
nature cooheritive ù est-on dans le
champ d'une d'une infraction au regard
des des dispositions fixées par la loi
nos outils sont sont simples il y a une
gradation la loi nous impose une
proportionalité dans nos interventions
la nature des des signalements qui nous
sont faits sont très variables c'est une
chose d'être saisie sur l'utilisation
d'un mot de frananglais par un animateur
qui est prohibé puisque nous sommes
censés défendre la loi la langue
française et nous y veillons c'est autre
chose d'être saisi sur une incitation
explicite à la haine une expression
raciste antisémite un appel à la la
violence il y a il y a bien évidemment
une gradation une gradation à avoir dans
nos interventions donc le premier degré
de nos interventions ça peut être une
simple mise en garde donc une alerte
qu'on adresse à l'éditeur en lui disant
attention là bon on n'a pas constaté en
tant que tel de manquement mais on
estime qu'il faut alerter néanmoins
l'éditeur parce que l'opinion publique a
pu être a pu être ému d'un d'un contenu
diffusé l'étape normale de notre
intervention c'est la mise en demeure
dès qu'on constate un manquement la loi
nous impose dans un premier temps de
prononcer une mise en demeure on ne peut
pas sanctionner directement immédiat la
loi impose de prononcer d'abord une mise
en demeure sur un motif précis et ce
n'est que si sur le même motif précis
qui a fait l'objet d'une mise en demeure
il y a réitération du manquement que
nous pouvons rentrer dans une procédure
de sanction qui passe par un rapporteur
indépendant un membre du Conseil d'État
qui ont transmet le dossier qui décide
lui-même si langage des
poursuites la liberté c'est lui qui joue
le rôle du procureur si je pu dire qui
instruit ensuite l'affaire de manière
contradictoire avec l'éditeur et au vu
de son rapport le collège de l'arcom est
à ce momentlà saisi convoque l'éditeur
qui est auditionné avec ses conseils et
le cas échéant statut et prononce s'il
le juge utille une sanction la gradation
des sanctions va de la publication d'un
communiqué on peut imposer à un éditeur
de publier un communiqué dont nous
rédigeons le texte une formule que nous
n'utilisons plus depuis déjà de
nombreuses années une sanction de nature
financière qui est celle que nous
utilisons le plus fréquemment qui peut
aller jusqu'à 4 % du chiffre d'affaires
de la société concernée 5% en cas de
récidive et la sanction ultime c'est le
retrait de l'autorisation de l'éditeur
qui bien évidemment ne peut se faire que
dans des cas vous l'imaginez très très
graves l'arcom ne l'a fait qu'une fois
sous mon prédécesseur et comme vous le
savez la décision du régulateur a été
annulée par le Conseil
d'État donc donc voilà la gradation de
nos de nos interventions je dis ici très
simplement que l'arcom n'hésite pas
chaque fois qu'un manquement caractérisé
est constaté mais encore faut-il qu'il
soit caractérisé précisément et qu'il a
une assise juridique solide au regard du
droit en vigueur et des jurisprudences
en vigueur la main de l'arcom et de son
collège ne tremble pas on a prononcé
cette année les sanctions les plus
élevées qu'on a prononcé dans toute
l'histoire de la régulation avec une
amende de 3 million et dei d'euros sur
un éditeur don c un peu plus de 4 % du
du chiffre d'affaires euh sous ma
présidence on a sanctionné pour la
première fois une chaîne d'information
avec une amende une amende significative
donc le régulateur n'hésite pas quand un
manquement caractérisé mais encore
faut-il qu' soit caractérisé j'insiste
sur ce point parce que notre droit une
fois encore est très protecteur de la
liberté il y a un arrêt topique de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qui dit bien les choses la liberté
d'expression c'est aussi des contenus
qui heurent et qui choquent c'est ça
l'essence de la liberté d'expression
c'est que chacun exprime un point de vue
un point de vue qui peut nous Horter qui
peut nous choquer mais qui aussi peut
faire évoluer notre analyse et le débat
démocratique vous êtes dans une enceinte
parlementaire votre quotidien c'est bien
ça c'est de vous opposer par des par des
points de vue parfois de façon très très
vive et au bout du compte le consensus
se dégage c'est ça l'essence de la
liberté d'expression et de la démocratie
mais le régulateur je le dis et
j'insiste là-dessus n'hésite pas à
utiliser les outils qui sont les siens
chaque fois qu'un manquement est
constaté ou caractérisé dans dans le
respect de la liberté et je réponds à
votre question monsieur le
Président le manquement d'un éditeur à
ses
obligations pour un éditeur qui
recandidaterait à ses fréquences un
manquement répété ou réitéré peut-être
naturellement un paramètre que le
régulateur peut-être amené à prendre en
compte ce n'est pas le seul paramètre la
loi indique bien les critères que nous
devons appliquer pour attribuer les
autorisations des matres pour attribuer
les
fréquences c'est notamment bien
évidemment au premier chef le pluralisme
c'est naturellement au premier chef
l'intérêt du téléspectateur mais le non
respect par un éditeur de ces obligation
est un paramètre que le régulateur peut
peut tout à fait prendre en compte dans
son processus de de de
décision puisque ce thème a été évoqué
sur l'appel à candidature qui vient donc
je bah je rappelle que bien évidemment
la décision qu'on prendra sera prise en
toute indépendance en toute
impartialité en toute
collégialité en transparence absolue
toutes les étapes de cette procédure est
sont transparentes consultation publique
je l'ai dit nous allons rendre les les
conclusions la synthèse de de cette
consultation publique dans quelques
jours étude d'impact je l'ai dit elle
sera publiée avant la fin de l'année
appel à candidature il interviendra au
début de l'année prochaine je l'ai dit
l'appel à candidature sera publié
audition publique des candidats comme
son nom l'indique c'est une audition
publique publication bien évidemment de
la liste des candidats présélectionnés
au terme de l'instruction de leur
dossier de candidature et des auditions
et puis bien évidemment les décisions
d'autorisation et les conventions que
nous sommes amenés à conclure sont rendu
publique le
calendrier nous amènera à boucler ce
dossier à à l'automne 2024 avec un appel
à candidature qui sera lancé début
24 remise des dossiers le temps
nécessaire aux candidats pour formuler
leur dossier audition publique analyse
des dossiers choix des candidats
attribution négociation des conventions
délivrance des autorisations et et
signature des des des conventions c'est
c'est une étape importante je réponds
puisque la question m'a été posée par
plusieurs d'entre vous cet appel à
candidature est l'occasion de repartir
d'une feuille blanche donc les candidats
représentent un dossier l'autorisation
tombe les fréquences sont libérées et
donc on lance un appel à candidature sur
ces 15 fréquences les candidats
présentent des dossiers ils sont libres
de présenter leur dossier ce n'est pas
l'arcom qui fixe un cahier des charges
c'est la liberté de communication qui
prime la liberté la liberté du commerce
et deindustrie donc ils présentent leur
dossier nous avons par contre des
critères posés par la loi pour les
choisir au premier chef le pluralisme et
bien évidemment l'intérêt du spectateur
l'équilibre économique du projet ça va
ça va sen
dire mais
c'est l'occasion de repartir d'une
feuille blanche et à cette occasion là
nous revoyons les termes des conventions
je répond très précisément à votre
question donc si vous regardez puisque
nous avons eu récemment le cas de TF1 et
M6 he qui nous a beaucoup occupé la
convention de TF1 la convention de M6 a
été revue nous avons agréé tout
récemment le changement de contrôle
d'EUR 1 avec la
commandite dont le gérant est Monsieur
Monsieur Arnaud lagarder donc ça c'est
un changement de contrôle de l'entité
europeopin à cette occasion nous avons
revu les termes de la convention sur de
nombreux points pour prendre en compte
l'évolution du paysage pour prendre en
compte l'évolution du cadre législatif
pour prendre en compte aussi ce qu'en
tant que régulateur nous avons été
amenés à observer euh au cours des au
cours des années des années écoulées
voilà donc pour cette audition du
président de LARCOM l'Autorité de
régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle l'idée était bien de de
faire le point sur la situation de la
télévision dans un environnement de plus
en plus concurrentiel les sénateurs
travaillent vous le savez depuis
plusieurs années sur l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel notamment de l'audiovisuel
publique il devrait en être à nouveau
question dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent c'est un sujet sur lequel
on reviendra bien évidemment sur Public
Sénat voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi restez
avec nous la formation politique
continue sur notre
[Musique]
antenne